define the term soulmates as you know it
ah that's a really good question hi i'm
ryan michelle bethe and i'm gonna answer
a few questions about love drew love
sexiest song in your playlist i'd have
to go current and say that uh the
jasmine sullivan song the hours and
hours and i can do this for uh the hours
honey all about the i like that stuff
best qualities in your partner his sense
of humor he's a very very funny man and
he is very goofy and he doesn't take
himself seriously and that is very sexy
he's like my my lack of charm is my turn
how does he say it the fact that i
i annoy you
but do it with charm is
it's he he does annoy me but he doesn't
do it with as much charm as he thinks so
we'll just put that there
and let's see
define the term soulmate as you know it
ah that's a really good question because
i feel like
i have so many soulmates i do feel like
there are so many people that you've had
these past life connections with and
it's like your soul
in whatever lifetime this lifetime i
don't know but like they meet and they
recognize each other and it's either
like let's complete that thing or oh my
god i'm so glad to see you remember what
we did last time okay girl we gonna cut
up this time we gonna cut up
and sometimes it's like that guy you
meet and you're like you feel like this
connection to them and it's you know
maybe it's cause in the past life you
know y'all have some some unfinished
situationships and you think it's your
soulmate he was not very nice in the
past life and your whole soulmate you
know your soul journey is to meet this
person and be like oh i don't really
like you
and that could be a soul mate too
anything that i think makes your soul
more
connected to its purpose i think is a
soul mate
okay how important is timing well
comedy we say timing is everything so
that's how important it is timing is
everything am i right if your life was a
rom-com who would play you me
me or jennifer lopez
what are the key ingredients to a happy
marriage sugar be sweet to your partner
be sweet be honest
and be as sweet and honest to yourself
as you are to your partner childhood
celebrity crush robert from the cosby
show i hope you learned about love and
thanks drew
you